bonjour françois durovray merci beaucoup
joué bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous en direct dans la matinale de rtl
france les huit départements de l'île de
france sont au dessus du seuil dallaire
pour le taux d'incidence le nombre de
cas augmente et les places en
réanimation sont en forte tension que
faut-il faire selon vous on attend
évidemment la conférence de presse de ce
soir mais quel est votre avis sur la
question
d'abord comme vous l'indiquez
effectivement la situation est très
tendue elle va continuer à se tendre
puisque les dans les semaines qui
viennent dans les hôpitaux il y aura
encore plus d'entrées que de sorties
donc je suis le fait partie des élus qui
ne s'opposeront pas à des mesures qui
soient proportionnées justifié et
accompagner maintenant nous sommes en
ile de france la situation est
évidemment beaucoup plus complexe que
dans d'autres régions françaises
et je n'imagine pas par exemple qu'il y
ait un confinement le week-end qui
s'ajoute au couvre-feu de la semaine ce
serait invivable pour nos concitoyens
dont il faut il fait partie des élus qui
ont été consultés j'ai demandé à ce que
des mesures proportionnées soient prises
oui donc on ne sait plus si vraiment il
y aura un confinement le week-end vous
dire vous me disiez ce sera très
compliqué à vivre pour les franciliens
pour quelles raisons l'île de france
fait elle figure d'exception par rapport
au pas de calais notamment qui subit ce
confinement le week-end par exemple il y
a deux éléments le premier c'est que
nous avons en ile-de-france des temps de
déplacement sont deux fois supérieurs à
ceux de la provence et donc des
contraintes au quotidien pour nos
concitoyens
et puis un autre élément c'est que 70 %
des franciliens vivent en appartement
or on sait que le virus satrape
principalement dans le milieu
professionnel ou dans le milieu familial
à domicile donc confiné les gens chez
eux ne résoudra pas forcément de la même
façon on ne permettra pas de la même
façon de lutter contre le virus que dans
d'autres régions françaises
je suis par exemple favorable au
maintien de l'ouverture des espaces
naturels
nous avons la chance d'avoir en ile de
france mais beaucoup moins de chances
d'attraper le virus dans un parc
le long des berges d'une rivière que
chez soi alors vous faites partie des
élus qui ont été consultés par emmanuel
macron dans quel état d'esprit était-il
emmanuel macron il avait fait le pari de
d'essayer de repousser évidemment cette
échéance du confinement
vous pensez qu'il va réussir son pari
manifestement le nom puisque de
nouvelles mesures vont être prises
moi ce qui m'inquiète le plus c'est
cette forme de commandites pas d'abandon
mais voyez je ne veux pas croire qu'on
laisse le virus maître du temps c'est
nous qui devrons prendre la main sur le
virus et on ne doit reprendre la main
sur des russes en testant davantage dans
mon département nous avons deux mythes
est seulement par semaine pour les
écoles il faudrait deux ans pour tt pour
les enfants mais faut que nous ayons
davantage de vaccins dans mon
département nous avons à date seulement
20 % des plus de 75 ans qui ont
bénéficié des deux injections alors que
c'est 40 % dans le jura pour que les
vaccins ait dans les régions sont les
plus touchés il faut plus de lits de
réanimation
je ne comprends pas pourquoi dans mon
département nous pouvons monter 468 de
l'animation
alors que nous étions est de 140 l'an
dernier et puis il nous faut enfin et
c'est la responsabilité des entreprises
et des citoyens plus de télétravail
parce qu'on se rend compte aujourd'hui
dans les transports publics
il y à beaucoup plus de monde qu'à
l'automne dernier donc plus de mesure
préventive plutôt que des mesures de
restriction est ce que le président vous
a répondu sur ces questions là alors je
n'ai pas eu des échanges directs avec le
président avec même une avec le feu
franchement aujourd'hui sont en phase de
consultation
même si on peut penser que certaines
options sont prisés notamment
je partage avec d'autres élus
l'inquiétude d'un couvre feu la semaine
à partir de 17h il serait à proprement
parler invivable pour nos concitoyens
mais
ils n'ont pas dévoilé au moment où nous
parlons deux options particulières
le couvre-feu a priori selon certains
experts ne fonctionne pas dans le pas de
calais donc c'est une mesure visiblement
qui ne fait pas ses preuves
à quoi vont l'appliquer pour paris c'est
la question je ne suis pas scientifique
et moi mon ma légitimité c'est que les
mesures prises soient socialement
acceptable faut évidemment mais
l'efficacité de ces mesures
elle c'est aux scientifiques qui veut
nous donner les éléments permettant
d'apprécier la situation et c'est
justement au vu de ce qu'ils disent que
j'estime que les parcs doivent rester
ouverts et j'estime qu'on ne doit pas
distinguer les commerces essentiel est
donnée essentielle mais qu'on doit fixer
des limites de deux nombres de personnes
pas cessé se prend des positions
politiques
aux vues considération alors valérie
pécresse à la présidente de région ile
de france aurait voulu être consultée
elle l'a dit hier n'a pas été convié au
déplacement du président dans un hôpital
de poissy regarder ce qu'elle a dit je
déplore que nous n'ayons pas été invitée
à son dépassement à poissy j'aurais pu
lui donner ma réponse de vive voix
est ce que c'est une fois de politique
selon vous ce manque en tout cas de
concertation avec les élus
ce qui est clair c'est que depuis un an
les élus locaux font preuve de
coopération avec l'état elle c'est
normal parce que lorsqu'il y à une
bataille à conduire de cette façon nous
devons tous être unis sur le front
ce qui éclaire également c'est que les
élus locaux sont beaucoup plus agile que
les plats pour acheter des masques pour
mettre en place des tests pour
accompagner l'état dans la bastille
nation et ce n'est pas à mettre en cause
les personnes c'est simplement que nous
avons des institutions qui sont plus
souples que celles de l'état et à chaque
fois le gouvernement l'état indiquent
des bonnes intentions dit on va terminer
on va davantage consultez les élus et à
chaque fois nous avons le sentiment
malheureusement ces bonnes paroles
m juste une dernière question très
rapidement
françois durovray ce que vous avez reçu
les fameuses autotests est ce qu'on va
pouvoir en acheter dans l'essonne dans
les supermarchés ce week end alors
j'espère je n'ai pas d'information
précise sur le sujet mais j'espère que
nous allons pouvoir multiplier les tests
j'étais avec valérie pécresse ignore ou
au genopole il ya beaucoup d'autres
solutions de test qui pour nous sont un
espoir de pouvoir mieux alerter et
anticiper sur le virus
merci beaucoup françois durovray d'avoir
répondu ce matin en direct à nos
questions sur rt france